I'm just gonna zoom in on you we have a
little boy here hi I'm just eating a
bagel and then we have me with a
scratchy throat yeah yeah I'm just a
little under the weather but look it
died we will prevail
yep with monkeys noise rachel is here
yeah I would this fly was saying I'm
like we should have totally just had
Rachel come out of here not have been so
amazing yeah she's not right what a
great surprise that would have been
though yeah this has been so Hiller it
it's like literally flipping keyboards
only right did you get to talk to Rachel
about it no no doctor about uh-huh I
didn't want to get her hopes like I
didn't want her to feel sad right yeah
this cuz I mean I'm just pretty sure she
would have wanted to fly out here too
for that I don't think that I mean it's
like a $500 plane ride whoa so Liam just
to come out for this like then she
probably wouldn't be able do it mm-hmm
but still would have been oh it would
have been so nice right
I wish so hard okay no she's the buzz
yeah she's pretty great the fuckin I
guess you could probably were there for
the 90s uh okay yeah no that's it'll
work now the gray hair is yeah thank you
that's Robert Rodriguez hair yeah what
kinda ya know it was where cuz we're
looking at it's like he's just a little
in the bag yeah
craziness going on um but nothing like
too long or too crazy so I was putting
out I what I don't know what Jim's like
oh yeah yeah we're going he's uh that
this yeah I don't think he has a beard
but I think it essentially this umm but
yeah here update well go ahead we'll
bring that to the office well he gets
that up here probably the pants oh oh oh
so you were saying thank you see her
fellas hey she's gonna be on her knees
uh I don't want to see legs if no a
kneeling and okay here's the thing I'm
gonna be sitting down the hose oh here
walk up to me and that is taller um I
mean I can't I just ever walk up on her
knees if you were gonna hmm like you
know what uh what we'll do her sister
well kiddo Obama but yeah I'm right that
is more kiddush yeah um yeah local
private what Oh
every boy wear those shoes every boy
weightless and every boy has kinda
mastiha so ya know what I like about
this this is stuff for like the UH you
know the game show and last week and
stuff like that this is all perfectly
acceptable from a IPS horse this really
works um okay so oh okay
yeah sorry Dan
little bro oh whoa yeah go ahead oh yeah
get a little water in this room right
now
oh you're the only boy in this room
right yes
little guys are our guys I'm hearing oh
no else lost in transit it's actually
Jim got that's a loss of translation
shirt actually find out cuz that's what
Bill Murray water yeah
I realize except in the movie I don't
think it said Lawson translate yeah oh
we heared yeah your get a closer you
think your clothes oh there you Lawson
that was against it I'll probably yeah
I'll bribe you sir like P crown you know
dad it doesn't try that if you're angry
angry spoiled Hollywood brats exactly
just translates to constipation I forget
I read this fare obsession yeah I
promise today isn't one week I didn't
read the script and I was so lost is a
week that we introduced hyper oh wow I
just like I don't read the script
no I did when I got here but before I
came I didn't so I have never done that
again oh yeah I said I think Rob for
waiting to the last minute to drop out
as Rachel I said I've gotta learn these
lines and he says no you don't Doug
shoots two lines out of tyre I can read
it and say it Oh Oh Rob dropped out is
reached by my nails oh why do you drop
out cuz he's a pussy oh no he won't be a
pussy that's the problem
you won't represent the pussy so wah-wah
so dad is now the official
representation can you point that out
this isn't No
the less you want for for those who
don't know how that we explained that we
are doing a for the nice and eccentric
DVD we are recreating the face of
footage that I deleted ah that we did
with Rachel the original episode we did
facing Rachel and getting Tamara mm-hmm
so but because uh we don't have Rachel
here we're just gonna have dad doing to
drag his cross-dressing is in drag you
told me to bring my normal clothes this
is well that's the surprise that's the
joke of this is that Rachel's were
doodly than any of us is is pretty yo
she gets home just like along that one
yeah she did wield that sword pretty
amazingly I would be saying we have to
recreate that picture of me cuz I'm
wearing a same outfit that I wear for
that review oh good go approach we're
gonna try uh so we're going to try we
have like a purple sweater I'm gonna try
for you because that's pretty the
closest your outfit um and yeah we're
gonna try and see if it's dead we start
said if not the clothes fit it could
just be fine you have Dan it is normal
clothes just a wig and lipstick oh you
holy always you have like itches Barney
Glenn just boom boom okay go I did yeah
but I like my skirt I've been pranking
switching it suing my Marcia Marcia
murder bit I mean I don't have ever seen
Rachel skirt yes true no no that there
was one review where she just like she
came in I want to is the bridge to
terabithia where she came in wearing
that I'm like oh you its are taken by
surprise like oh yeah I forgot you do
that okay what's your on
what's your boy boys that should not be
just like a little boy like how old's
what do you want my son
um I mean like a your see goo troop
yeah you know that kind of boys go ahead
what's going on yeah that's it that's
about good yeah that's very good squirt
would help a deck you bring anything
look you bringing the script that says
the plot on that I think a young in the
room thank you
the poop I think that should turn into
our just script every time I like that
this is the plot yes I know that that's
how I tell the difference with um like
the one that has my dogs and the one set
you know actors it just was also it
works now what I did for the the frozen
to video it you know cuz that's what the
leat script it just like the plot and
now just like I just can't believe like
my script 3000 is the script now it's
awesome the point okay so I'm gonna be
here yeah he's are there hi face dad
whoa no thanks pops
what the cop and he's rich haha cars and
chips that's that jacket she gets here I
reckon
chick-fil-a that's chick-fil-a
chick-fil-a MSR just some last minute oh
sure smiler stay we're home vote cuz
you're delicious right if only they
weren't um waffle fries they I did try
some waffle fries so Tara Jimmy figure I
come up about right here
these and everything okay yeah actually
that look okay okay yeah yeah but a
friend of mine was i eating from
chick-fil-a and I just like stole a
waffle fry Mike that's really good
that's like him only delicious only they
weren't filled with hate very well yeah
we're just feeling hate looks like man
hate and carbs yeah
Sabbath like the only really openly
Christian right like super bigoted it's
like she could represent the Lord in
love
hey no batik yeah we love with hate love
hate but hurts that's a ticket you're
all today that's what I hear it is good
chicken maybe that's the secret oh my
gosh
oh so he can't be Rachel why did you
think he can be Rachel since he's here I
thought he couldn't be here or something
right no no he can you just check it out
oh so he doesn't want to be in the
Rachel later people a doubt you
chick-fil-a doubt you get that joke
everybody gets to hit you come on what
is it that this is overseas behind the
scenes it was a funny discussion oh yeah
so I made some crack against gay people
and
I know in a nutshell
nothing it really is nothing oh I don't
know I just show up dress up and then
say we're lines that that's how I know
he uh yeah it's a good country she is
going to play Robert Rodriguez's son
rocket that is his real name Rocket
Raccoon no I I could also see the
screenwriter D you get in there already
I was just testing it already I don't
like races that's racers racer do you
make okay okay
yes it was amazing incredible yes
let me see medics now yes I want to see
it I mean okay
okay here Tamra here's the thing though
did you like the ending of return the
King that big climax yes that's the
whole movie it's just one big climax
that's amazing it's an amazing moment I
think the most beautiful action film
ever
yeah it's just like this gorgeous
looking filled but in terms of like you
know yeah you know the story and
characters were really good and really
chance he's like no it's just shit blown
up but it looks amazing
ya know it's really good so okay
alright you want to run through sure
alright so when I say actually just wait
about five seconds and then come in okay
Oh Malcolm you're gonna have to get out
of a shot Oh Hollywood spoil Brett ooh
translates to constipation last person
you put have to do this yeah you just
roll it off I could roll it for you guys
well what is that what is that sighs you
go by
all right bad pop-tarts yes that would
have been perfect that is a pop-tarts
commercial yeah
pop-tarts cardboard and spackle and fake
blueberries yes
but they were so tasty yeah
blueberry pop-tarts it's more of a
cherry person cheering yeah like cheery
but without the frosting just like the
plain tart cherry yeah I said it fussing
was weird
get one and then they always kind of
melted in a strange wing the toaster and
then that fighting now here's the thing
they have to it's like drywall or
something like yeah rival Street ripping
I don't know like chips sweet give
reason paint chips no I had a few
growing up I grew up in money so oh yeah
it's it's yeah it's like paint chips
only sweeter in dispensers and this is
what I meant to grow up in the 80s man
everything was out to kill us yeah yeah
nineties row about bright saturated
skittles colors yeah like the 80s for
more like that kind of pink I think
we're quite pastel it's like hot blue
hot pink yeah do we send the 90s were
all about like it was like hair things
are good saturated colors yeah more
moody let's yeah let's use those for
Tamara at least like a couple scrunchies
and stuff we ought to go quite as crazy
as last time and I think le component
yeah a duet on flannel is also I don't
remember on commercials though oh oh so
it's supposed to be it's like a 90s
commercial yeah tie-dyeing
would be the best yeah get Ida
thing um great show guys pretty pretty
sure does anyone know where it is
the Auto Mall we could just go by one
did just a big pink shirt it's why I
start seeing chuck-e-cheese commercials
where he's on rollerblades
chuck-e-cheese do the extreme like don't
even don't even are you fucking kid I
yeah I'm like it's fucking Chuckie
Cheese come on King extreme sports
extreme cheese honestly would Richie
please think of Lewis's 90s kid and I'm
just like yeah that's a pretty good
summer way I was thinking of having like
we just do okay Apple Jacks that's there
for their 90s I can't do no we what we
like it's an apple jacks 93 what they
don't taste like those we know the
bubble Tate's are my favorite song you
know what your teacher does not like
bubble tea so that means you do what is
Maris Dante on in six feet of bubble gum
for you hm yeah and everything in the
90s was like it's us versus them man
right it's the kids versus the adult
they are out to fucking get you exactly
was the 80s was different you kind of
wanted to be an adult it was always
about gritty and sneaking into cinemas
to see r-rated movies and drinking beer
and doing all the horrible things that's
supposed to do yeah the horrible thing
is in the 90s the horrible thing was
bubble tape adults don't want that like
that's a thing it's like adults really
didn't care but they tried to make it
look like or I would care and that was
like the marketing ploy yes I like her
what anybody says the ghostbusters smoke
like fucking chimneys we're liking
cinnamon toast crunch commercials is
like the adults didn't get it Oh what
are those cinnamon swirlies yeah which
don't understand dad I thought you were
like smoking a J every day don't you
just eat a box of this shit yeah that's
what I can't understand why they're so
good
markley they don't taste exactly like
nacho cheese I don't understand your dad
have another pot brownie no I got it
yeah got me something like just all the
nineties parents to all the nineties
commercials grown-ups like in one place
edge of the horse my bowtie most another
didn't you grow up in the 60s you must
have seen some weird shit really
Cinnamon Toast Crunch is it a diamond
shape these tan lines hey what's
happening it's totally Tamara Tara
coming up next on Disney huh uh 36 36 38
- really yeah whoa Malcolm like the
exact same size on everything so this um
that doesn't fit it so hey let's give
her one of my shirts yay looking totally
Tamara I said that needs to be the thing
okay the jacket on but then we need like
another jacket tied around I don't know
how does this work
I mean you just put on your finger yeah
I've got a little brush you use um but
I'd melted them down so it doesn't take
up so much space
okay just I see you take a brush and
it's like water
I've got no it's um it's it's lipstick I
just cut it off and then melted it down
so it wasn't in like 30 different tubes
okay whatever if if when we can figure
out how to get that on to him baby yeah
I've got yeah I've got a brush this is
gonna be interesting
sorry
face off review behind the scenes take
two yes yeah yeah I think so too
um okay uh let's see let's see it all
together it actually is funnier if you
look like one yen our work no that's
total Rico um no I'm with them I think
that you look up to your high doesn't
look like a dude yeah so I think go
ahead rob us which the jeans then it I
think it's a good idea see you have any
like slacks or something well here you
wear Miami
so you said oh no yeah where is it sure
yeah sure sure
sure dad sure yeah sure um okay well
while they're doing that I bring a film
the scene with you Oh tell me what's up
where did you come from right
we don't have I'll pick the lice out
there and there's not enough steel wool
to scrub this out of my eyes and it's
like so got your mind uh huh I dare oh
god I'm gonna be on drugs for a long
long time
what no that's camera Oh like okay we
can use its cave Rachel it's the front
of this brush we can we brush it front
eyeshadow I'll wait till he's
and then rude yeah it just needs to be
brushed what we were saying Rachel does
not rock the table so look generally
speaking
she's doing it now Tamara's like no she
doesn't
for the most part from us perfect they
live together she's seen things she's
seen as you people wouldn't believe
oh man what did what did she call Rachel
adieu Glee or doodly what what are you
talking abou Rach we were talking of
weird when we were I don't know if you
were even here yet we're talking about
something and she said Oh Rachel was a
real I said ugly doodly or something
like that and I have no idea what it
meant so I and know let's ask Tamara it
was the hanger yeah we're you must
camera you got some splainin to do Wow
where did they go actually Rossellini
she is full of turtle meat well what
does that mean vixen camera no oh it's
amazing
did you ever watch Mystery Science
Theater 3000 I did and I've seen it you
should have seen camera cuz it's amazing
huh about this giant turtle bit it's
kind of like an answer to Godzilla
we had a turtle that spins around like a
spaceship is like it's into sewing
didn't they fight yeah I think there was
an episode where they thought then
there's gamma on versus GUI on he's like
a giant space turtle Oh money makes some
world Korra there's no business like
show business you can use it for
eyeshadows oh did you see that age thing
how old that net posted I hosted no what
was it I'll just link you to it
I would - how old do you have to be to
still dress up like a woman no it's all
know it's called how old that net and
you just post a picture and the program
gives you an age of what they think how
old you look oh I did then they told me
I was the Cryptkeeper so though I posted
the group photo of all of us with uh
with yeah oh you saw it yeah yeah I
posted the group photo we took with 19 a
Civil War general Civil War general so
what did what did your say mom um it
gave me 35 he gave me yeah I'm like what
it gave Jim 36 oh I know
it gave Tamra Fitz cueing you guys that
open I've got to be like 80 it's at 51
for you but get this it says oh who ever
designed that program you go fuck
yourself
your fucking ass Minoo and then it gave
Barney 46
you know eyelids all that eyeshadow
right
he gave it also gave Doug 46 and then it
gave Dante 25 ahead of all of the corn
bloody drinks right we give him some
glitter but no the actually can we do a
remake of Twitter starring him uh but
yeah I got a bunch of shares I'm
surprised and it didn't get around to
you guys cuz it was pretty funny
maybe I blocked it out of my memory 5200
maybe it's all surface cuz I'm all got
six was born in the 80s that there was
born in the late seventies not them
early sixties right no the I think the
program's off cuz I did another picture
of me and Tamra and it likes a 27 for me
and then like aged her like a couple of
years so I think it's just based on like
the lighting in various things cuz I
thought that was funny though it made
Barney and Doug the same age and you're
like older than both of them you gotta
sleep quiet you you look like a
cross-dressing Colonel Sanders
oh look at Santa Christ don't I ask him
about the secret herbs and spices Oh
delicious the herbs some lipstick and we
ever made yeah I will have Rachel know
now we've got no I'll Rob out there
somewhere is my is my shirt yes I'll fix
you your
no no my mascara please you know I
actually did use it mascara when I had
darker darker mustache because I would
fill it in
Oh fill in like with pepper yeah with a
slit to you with the mascara the only
trouble is when I cried my mustache ran
OH
your mascara dad like neighs Rob I'll be
crying in the corner well I don't know
I've never done this on my life well
let's wait for Tamara Tamara dude then
did you say you put mascara on your
mustache oh yeah because it it don't
know I
it was nothing down here so I would just
you and Dumbo oh yeah
where do you think he learned it before
old why we shared our master watching
you Hey wow I'm learning so many things
this pretty much explains all of my
neuroses all of them all of them every
single one just like mom she's like I
just work here oh yes try it okay how do
i hook her up
mm-hmm and I like like that just like
duck lips is amazing
have you ever puckered up for another
man before it's a very experimental time
it's like a train wreck I want to look
away but I came anity oh ha what yeah
it's a variety of it oh my how am I
gonna explain this I know I'm like I
came here to sober that was my mistake
well you know it could have been you in
the seat mm-hmm God for that I don't
think I would have been as funny as this
maybe I don't know either way it would
have been funny I was starting to think
about what I would do it's like I'm
working on this Santa Christ thing right
now so that's part of it I'm too
invested in that I to writing a origin
story for Santa Christ oh man so every
time I think of white characters I keep
thinking of Santa cries I'm like I don't
know how to make this funny I kept
wanting to do a Santa Christ voice it's
not what this needs
yeah you gotta
with a nice board and you've got a
pretty mouth heard it oh yeah there boy
whoa
please don't hear that well we'll see
what the behind-the-scenes fairy guides
us
I think fairies a good word right yeah
that's uncanny it was ready to her in
front of us yes that Rachel's beard - oh
yeah what do I do here
eyes open shut what eyes white shell
open know if this is gonna work he
doesn't have beautiful eyelashes like I
do
well then we'll just have to cast you
maybe I can SS be nice yeah yeah it's
just ready but I mean that's how she
wears it it's on camera it's on camera
it's on Tamra
cameras on here yes smile you're on
camera can the TAM can yo give Li she is
never called like in a revealing or
anything that like Tamra came that Tamra
where the sneak long in me reg okay
thank you I'm sorry yeah Rachel oh yeah
you try to ponytail it wasn't in front
of her fan and she had on like behind
her ears though can we do that
isn't that the name of your Instagram
blue the Tamara camera yeah okay I was
gonna say like it you must use their
force at least one of the two on cam
yeah Africa don't seem to help yeah how
would you do the eyebrows - mm-hmm show
me to do this like and make them look
like guys know what you can say dudes
don't know how to do good maker
I am so insulted by that no no please do
what you can Tamara we men's rights
activist - animus minuteness
is that what they're called oh I don't
know no no no that's true that
well that's jargon term for them to say
that they're menace cuz they are like be
you're nothing yeah cuz the mailman
where are you yet men's rights is
nothing going and then like that was it
it was just like yeah no no it's one of
those things where it's like there's
definitely shit I mean there's stuff
like some things men get screwed out on
don't get me wrong and gender roles and
stuff but it's like compared to the shit
women go through a little excited I
don't think it's enough for like a
movement oh I'm right rude my man max oh
that was the best are you doing about
the article that I wrote yeah like I'm
like okay well it's clear you never saw
the movie cuz like I was like this I was
sitting in the movie waiting for and I'm
like man like Mad Max is all over this
movie he barely takes orders from
anybody like I'm like what's this dude
talking about oh well I in a day Eddie
let's take orders from a woman go no I'm
like aliens where you know she's giving
orders to Space Marines at the end and
it really just comes down to her and the
other mama aliens saving a child well
there doesn't cure all it's a bro
feminine piece but my action movie how
dare James go say go steady a flag
that's just yeah Mendes I'm sure you're
calling something else I'm just calling
you idiots dude
nope men in this yep that's what they're
cold like a seconds I'm sure this like
lid like equal right stuff you could
talk about with that
yeah like man said just like go we just
don't take orders from women and wait a
minute trying to ruin everything it's
like oh yeah nailed it right I see that
recent interview just watch promotions
and my action move did I get explosions
yes did I get a bunch of a biscuit let
me hot women wish we get hat cheese
chicken did you see that Fox interview
recently where well you started off yeah
so no let's just assume no this guy was
on there saying how like feminists
choose to be unhappy and then one just
to marry it like a guy they would be
that's where their happiness would come
from and like there was a woman we all
don't like you'd be happier if you were
at home no my husband beats me
horrifically you'd be a baby with that
it'd be good football player yeah there
we'll build a kitchen around you and
Frank Nate you know what Fox News are
just ready to do this like we have a
staff just ready to you know sizzle
woman says yes just go ahead make the
kitchen around you fair and balanced
kitchen hey Kimmy it can be whatever you
want just something that looks confusing
in geometry and if you want to connected
a little rings oh I remember this yeah
yeah I was just a kid
yeah that's just a kid it was so long
ago
Oh year and a half
I think I have this scene in my behind
the scenes audio yeah Jerald not past if
I if I put the video I probably I
probably have the scene where I'm
recording Rob actually write something
Sarge look at this look at my vine so we
just got that it was a good I mean ii be
too often you get to see Kearney dressed
like this
well yes cuz you're not around my house
Oh what is happening no scandal and is
that Batman no no that's a bell wrong
hmm
have you ever seen Lord of the Rings no
well there's your problem
I have it ah I can't believe is not a
great phrase the gray race you've never
seen agree the Navy you've never seen
the great race nobody seen the great
racing though they should yes one of the
best comedies ever made
really yeah why do you like Looney tune
no know what I'm doing out there this is
love and shit if there's a lot of a lot
of nostalgia Craig has gotten from one
of the characters okay I in it so it's
it played by Jack Lemmon it's oh yeah we
love it but it's not for everybody okay
looks like a lake in which it's a good
flow yeah great don't worry Rachel when
you wake up you'll be
entirely new person back don't worry
don't worry Rachel don't worry - when
you wake up he'll be an entirely new
person in fact she won't be having new
people Oh Bob oh I'm sorry
yeah you have to actually go we're not
gonna see you so you can just say yeah
so it's gonna stay on her the whole time
whatever you want like a kodos King it's
it's both it's a taste I'm gonna be the
shot after the Panna once it gets up
maybe does he want to move so that I can
like not feel whoa what what we could do
is like when you actually start make
them yeah you could actually get up like
I don't know I'll slide this way I'll
get all you're gonna hit Ron Oh Oh ours
oh yes oh man - I got hit we're you all
right were you gonna be robbed when you
okay got it
I'm fine and I can still see you're okay
with the light you're not blocking a
life in